welcome back everybody on this friday
and it is time right now for what's
trending with the fabulous mercedes
martinez joining us
live from the mix 94.1 studio hey
mercedes happy friday to you
same to you alex so good to see you this
morning the mtv
vmas are trending the 2020
mtv vma nominations were announced and
ariana grande lady gaga and billy eilish
all lead the ways very good year for the
ladies
gaga and ariana they have nine
nominations
seven of which are for this song right
here rain on me
huge hit billy she ended up picking up
six for her debut album when we all fall
asleep where do we go
and they actually have a couple of new
categories that they're adding this year
including
best music video from home and best
quarantine performance so that should be
pretty interesting i want to ask you
alex the
artist of the year nominees include the
baby
justin bieber lady gaga megan the
stallion
and post malone in the weekend who's
your pick for best
oh that's so hard i like i'm a big pokey
fan
but what do you say i i actually i'm
going to go with
lady gaga on that one i think it was a
big year for her so
also trending this morning couple goals
trending
and a new study has come out saying that
couples who
share power equally in a relationship
tend to be happier and they found that
more power balanced couples have a
higher quality relationship
the reasons though are different for men
and women for men
their happiness decreases when they
perceive themselves as having less or
more power than their partner
and for ladies they're less happy when
their partner had a very dominant
personality so some interesting
relationship news there
and then pumpkin spice latte is trending
is it too soon i know
tomorrow is august but word is it's
coming back and it's coming back soon
uh i guess starbucks confirmed it on
their annual earnings call
and uh so we don't have a start date and
when it's going to come back but i'll
just let you know last year it came back
on august 27th so you may be enjoying
your psl very soon alex
yes with our 112 degrees so looking
forward i know
mercedes we don't know if you can get
back to the radio so we'll let you go
thank you for joining us hope you have a
great weekend thank you
you too bye-bye we'll see you next week
bye